nur weil donald trump von den großen
plattformen verband wurde diskutieren
wir auf einmal wieder bei
meinungsfreiheit im netz
und plötzlich fällt an wieder auf eine
handvoll unternehmen entscheidet was wir
im internet sehen und was eben nicht
und die ganz große frage wo sind die
ganzen und wer entscheidet eigentlich
darüber
und während diese diskussion import von
tram ganz viel und ganz groß diskutiert
wird läuft eine andere entwicklung ganz
unterm radar
seit 2007 gibt es das global internet
foren zu counter terrorism kurz kid city
habt ihr noch nie gehört hatte ich auch
nicht falls doch schreibt sie mich gerne
und in die kommentare
das gift cities auch auf druck der eu
und anderer regierungen entstanden die
großen giganten youtube twitter facebook
und microsoft haben sich im kampf gegen
terrorismus zusammengeschlossen
im kern geht es um eine gemeinsame
datenbank die extremistische und
terroristische inhalte wie zb aus
christchurch aus dem internet fähigen
soll das problem ist das ganze ist
ziemlich undurchsichtig und interessant
jetzt machen sich
menschenrechtsorganisationen und
kritiker in sorgen um die
meinungsfreiheit die juristen und
wissenschafterinnen sieht in dem projekt
sogar das am stärksten unterstützte
projekt für die zukunft der
meinungsfreiheit und auch die ehemalige
europaabgeordnete julia ritter ist sehr
skeptisch
ich denke es ist keine gute entwicklung
wenn am ende mark zuckerberg entscheidet
was im internet läuft und was nicht die
da war ich das gitti wird aktuell von 20
plattform gefüttert gehostet wird sie
von facebook
ich frage mich jetzt schon ist das gibt
steve wirklich eine gefahr für die
grundrechte oder brauchen wir das gegen
terror kann die meinungsfreiheit
wirklich von einer plattform abhängen
ohne dass wirklich jemand davon erfährt
der medienwissenschaftler pascal ihres
ist da zurückhaltender ich würde jetzt
erst mal nicht den teufel an die wand
malen wahrscheinlich sind die meisten
instrumente von dittmann so
normalerweise internetzensur sagen würde
sind gar nicht so schlimm wenn sie in
demokratischen staaten genutzt werden
naja mich hat das ganze jedenfalls
super neugierig gemacht ich habe mich
deshalb für euch durch
unterschiedlichste stellen gegraben
paper gelesen und mich mit ganz viel
internet regulierung auseinandergesetzt
ja und was ich herausfinden konnte das
könnt ihr euch jetzt einfach angucken
ich werde euch zuerst mal erklären worum
es überhaupt geht was die
hauptkritikpunkte daran sind und dann
natürlich darauf eingehen warum das
gibt's die was ist was wir schon alle
kennen sollten
[Musik]
im hintergrund zusammengearbeitet wurde
schon länger aber 2017 ist daraus das
gitti entstanden denn der druck auf die
internetkonzerne wurde größer nachdem in
europa in paris und in brüssel mehrere
terroranschläge verübt wurden endlich
sich darum zu kümmern ihre inhalte
besser zu regulieren
das ziel der ganzen geschichte ist
eigentlich folgendes terroristische
inhalten extremismus sollen ganz schnell
plattformübergreifend aus dem internet
verschwinden und so diese datenbanken da
sind zu verhindern das ist eine schnelle
breite dramatische verwaltung wird von
so videos wo man sagen will
moment mal als gesellschaft haben uns
geeinigt wir wollen keine köpfe und
videos wir wollen keine fürchterlichen
misshandlungen des ganzen sachen das
wollen wir nicht sehen es ist irgendwie
gegen unsere würde auch gegen unsere
vorstellung davon was in medien gezeigt
werden soll und deswegen wollen wir das
und dafür haben sich dann vier der
einflussreichsten plattform
zusammengeschlossen und eine gemeinsame
datenbank geschaffen
die gründungsmitglieder sind facebook
twitter youtube und microsoft
mittlerweile gehören 16 weitere
plattform und provider dem gap city an
und sie alle haben zugriff auf das
herzstück die datenbank tja und diese
datenbank wird von plattformen mit
informationen über illegale und als
terroristisch markierte inhalte
gefüttert das sind anonymisierte hashes
also digitale fingerabdrücke von bildern
oder videos in der datenbank liegen also
nicht die bilder oder videos selbst und
wenn jetzt ein mitglied inhalt als
illegal kennzeichnet und in die
datenbank einspeist verschwinden die von
allen plattformen die auf die datenbank
zugreifen
je nachdem wie deren technologie ist
entweder sofort oder erst nach einer
prüfung außerdem lassen sich dann
inhalte die so gehetzt wurden durch
upload filter auch nicht mehr hochladen
und das auch auf keine der plattform
das gift ist ja noch relativ jung und
verändert sich aktuell auch noch ständig
als 2009 10 das attentat von
christchurch 16 minuten lang live
facebook gespielt werden konnte war die
empörung groß denn für live inhalte gab
es kein konzept wieder auf den
plattformen noch in der city also kam
politik und wirtschaft zusammen und
anschließend wurde ein krisen protokoll
verabschiedet
wenn das ausgelöst wird können
sicherheitsbehörden jetzt direkt inhalte
an das gästeteam melden
zum allerersten mal eingesetzt wurde das
krisen protokoll dann in halle dort sind
die bilder des attentats relativ schnell
von den großen plattform verschwunden
das klingt erst mal gut und dass es eben
die eine seite der medaille die andere
seite ist dass es keine rechtsstaatliche
kontrolle darüber gibt was denn da
überhaupt gesperrt wird und genau darin
sehen ganz viele eine gefahr für die
meinungsfreiheit julia rede die ihr
vielleicht noch vom kampf gegen upload
filter und die urheberrechtsreform kennt
ist sehr sehr skeptisch was das kid city
angeht die fehlende demokratische
kontrolle isd 1 ihre hauptkritikpunkte
das bedeutet nicht also dass solche
dinge wie eben bilder von attentaten
nicht gesperrt werden dürfen sondern das
problem ist dass es niemals dabei bleibt
und das sehen wir ja auch jetzt schon
beim glaube internetforum also es ist ja
mitnichten so dass dort ausschließlich
bilder von gewalttaten gesperrt werden
sondern alles mögliche was halt unter
diesen sehr schwammigen begriff der
terroristischen propaganda fällt nur mal
so zur größenordnung im juli 2020 lagen
ungefähr 300.000 hashes in der datenbank
das schreibt mir der geschäfte gitti mit
rasmussen über seinen sprecher
aktuellere angaben hatte allerdings
nicht von diesen 300.000 sind ungefähr
250.000 hashes von fotos 50.000 welche
von videos welche inhalte das jetzt
genau sind es bleibt unter verschluss
aber es gibt eine aufschlüsselung die
wir uns jetzt mal zusammen angucken
können und zwar sind 16,9 darstellung
von gewalt
wehrlose menschen also dinge wie mord
enthauptung und so weiter 21 prozent
fallen unter radikalisierungen
recruiting und anleitung an minimal
anteil von 0 1% im glaubwürdige
unmittelbar bevorstehende androhung von
gewalt insgesamt 8,9 prozent werden den
attentaten vom kreistag halle und
geländern zugeordnet und der mit abstand
aber allergrößte teil ist mit 72 prozent
terror verherrlichung und das ist
definiert als inhalte die angriffe
nachträglich verherrlichen logen oder
feiern und das ist dann schon im
vergleich zu den anderen die schwammige
kategorie trotzdem klingt das jetzt
erstmal verständlich dass alles zu
löschen aber eine frage ist dabei ganz
elementar wichtig was ist den
terrorismus
und wer entscheidet überhaupt was
terrorismus ist was ist denn wenn am
ende
friday is for future oder andere
umweltgruppen als terroristisch
eingestuft werden wenn
menschenrechtsgruppen als terroristisch
eingestuft werden
wer entscheidet denn was als
terroristische inhalte geht
und selbst in der eu können wir uns da
nicht darauf einigen das würden viele
gemeinsame definition haben wie soll das
weltweit funktionieren in der eu wurden
anti terror gesetze zum beispiel in
spanien schon gegen separatisten und in
frankreich schon gegen geld besten
eingesetzt das stand auch kraß in der
kritik das zeigt aber das ist immer so
ein bisschen schwammig ist und dann
bleibt schon die frage an welchen regeln
oder an welchen richtlinien orientiert
sich dann ein globales internetforum
ihren aktuell entscheiden das ganz
einfach die plattform
sie entscheiden in ihren agb was sie
selbst als ziel definieren und diese
doch sehr unterschiedlich von plattform
zu plattform manchmal steht einfach nur
da das darstellung von gewalt gelöscht
werden anderes mal geht es wirklich um
terrorismus und es sind wirklich
definitionen vorhanden und im zweiten
schritt geht es an die content
moderation der einzelnen plattformen
weil sich daher dann ganz klar
entscheidet was wird denn dann
ich wirklich gelöscht was wird
eingespeist und wie genau werden die
inhalte dann entdeckt läuft das ganze
automatisiert über künstliche
intelligenz oder gibt es wirklich noch
prozesse wo menschen noch mal drauf
schauen auch dass das von plattform zu
plattform unterschiedlich und alle haben
dann aber zugriff und die möglichkeit
dinge in die datenbank einzusteigen
aktuell liegen laut gibbs die team nur
caches in der datenbank deren inhalt
sich auf organisation bezieht die auf
der un terrorliste gelistet sind oder
aber inhalte die durch die krisen
protokoll ausgelöst werden das heißt
also halle alles was die plattform sonst
noch als terrorismus auf ihre eigenen
plattform definiert ist zumindest stand
nicht teil der herstatt bank coop city
ja mal wirklich zufrieden sind die damit
nicht das hat mir eine krasse müssen in
seiner e-mail geschrieben und es auch
eine november in einem podcast erklärt
warum auf der un liste sind fast
ausschließlich terroristen und
organisationen mit islamistischem
hintergrund das heißt das könnte dazu
führen dass auf der seite des spektrums
überreguliert wird das heißt zu viel
gelöscht und auf jeder anderen seite des
spektrums also zb bei rechten terror
unter reguliert das heißt zu wenig
gelöscht werden so rasmussen
und ein grund ist wohl dass es weder bei
der uno noch bei den regierung wirklich
definition für andere form von
terrorismus gibt deswegen arbeitet jetzt
an einer eigenen mac der ganzen
diskussion auch an
der blick der gitti auf terrorismus und
extremismus ist ein amerikanischer das
ist auch nicht weiter verwunderlich denn
die krassesten ist kein neuer in diesem
geschäft er war 27 jahre lang anti
terror bekämpfe der amerikanischen
regierung
und weil das alles so schwierig ist
steht für kritikerin julia frieda
folgendes fest für terrorismus sollte es
so eine organisation nicht geben weil
das ein viel zu kontext sensitives thema
ist um zu sagen es gibt schwarz weiß die
terroristischen inhalte die wir nicht
haben wollen und es gibt auf der anderen
seite die die legal sind also dafür ist
das thema viel zu komplex künstliche
intelligenz ist da auch nicht immer so
schlau wie sich intelligenz da
vielleicht anhört vor allen dingen bei
automatisierten verfahren passieren auch
immer wieder fehler das heißt inhalte
und kontext werden nicht erkannt und so
konstant sodass dinge gelöscht werden
die eigentlich legal sind und stehen
bleiben sollten das sind zum beispiel
journalistische berichte dokumentation
von kriegsverbrechen oder auch videos
von menschenrechtsorganisationen und das
führt uns wiederum zum nächsten problem
wer entscheidet denn dann was gelöscht
wird
und auch hier gilt die plattform
entscheiden entlang ihrer agb mit ihrer
technik und ihren ressourcen was sie wie
als terroristisch markieren und wie sie
das dann sperren
und in diesem prozess passieren
natürlich auch fehler
wenn jetzt so ein fehler passiert ist es
bei einer plattform schon nicht so schön
aber wenn jetzt alle plattformen
zusammen in so einer harten dank hängen
ist das problem natürlich ungleich
größer jetzt wird befürchtet dass zum
beispiel passieren könnte wenn eine
plattform fehler macht das in die
datenbank einspeist und dass dann
automatisch aus allen plattformen
verschwindet mir kraft und schreibt das
so dass die inhalte nicht automatisch
und direkt sofort gesperrt werden
das war aber lange unklar und er
schreibt auch einige mitglieder könnten
sich dafür entscheiden die erstarrten
beim vollständig zu treten
während andere robustere und
vielfältigere methoden und tools
verwenden die mit den unternehmens agb
übereinstimmen ja und das heißt aber
seitz ist es völlig unklar wie die
einzelnen plattformen umgehen das heißt
die mitglieder müssen einander vertrauen
und in der praxis ist es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass gerade klein
hat form die nicht so viel ressourcen
haben die datenbank nutzen um inhalte
automatisch zu sperren weil sie einfach
nicht die ressourcen haben diesen
einzelnen inhalten zu überprüfen
die sorge ist hier natürlich das finde
ich eigentlich auch das ist das größte
problem das bei gc die flucht ins
privatrecht geschieht also dass
praktisch private unternehmen zu einem
mega behörde werten die im grunde
genommen im hintergrund sachen machen
die niemand so richtig kontrolliert das
heißt es entscheidet eben nicht ein
demokratisch gewähltes gremium was im
internet erlaubt ist und was nicht
sondern letzten endes entscheiden
private unternehmen und zwar nicht nur
unter dem gesichtspunkt was gut für die
gesellschaft ist sondern auch was
wirtschaftlich gut für die plattformen
ist
ich denke es ist keine gute entwicklung
wenn am ende mark zuckerberg entscheidet
was im internet läuft und was nicht eine
demokratische kontrolle ist aktuell
peter da noch denkbar und außerdem steht
die frage im raum wie groß ein möglicher
staatlicher einfluss auf dieses
konsortium ist es gibt keinen direkten
zugang nationaler sicherheit behörden
auf die herstatt bank das schreiben wir
das bundesinnenministerium und das kid
city übereinstimmen
aber das bka kam über europol inhalte an
die plattform melden mit der anregung
diese zu entfernen und zwischen 2015 und
2019 wurden laut bundesregierung so
96.000 166 hinweise an 112 druck weiter
gemeldet
ob die dann wiederum was an gitti
weitergegeben haben es unklar
aber in 84 prozent der anregung wurde
dann auch gelöscht obwohl die plattform
nicht dazu verpflichtet sind
diese entwicklung sind wichtig denn die
eu will in den nächsten monaten eine
neue terrorwarnung verabschieden und
nach aktuellem stand sind
plattformbetreiber dann verpflichtet
terroristische inhalte auf anordnung
nationaler behörden ohne richterlichen
beschluss innerhalb von einer stunde zu
löschen und kritiker innen sehen jetzt
darin ganz klar die gefahr dass so der
druck auf plattform wächst zu handeln
und das den dann quasi gar nichts
anderes übrig bleibt als ich
im konsortium wie der big city
anzuschließen
und wenn jetzt letzten endes behörden
aus allen möglichen ländern nicht nur in
der eu sondern weltweit empfehlungen
geben können ein private unternehmen
hier schaut euch diesen inhalt doch mal
an der könnte terroristisch sein
und dann diese unternehmen auf basis
ihrer privaten regeln entscheiden dass
diese inhalte praktisch aus dem gesamten
internet verschwinden weil ja alle
möglichen plattformen dieselbe datenbank
nutzen
dann ist das ein sehr leicht missbrauch
bares zensurinstrument für behörden für
staatliche stellen die sich eben nicht
an einen demokratischen prozess halten
und ein gerichtsurteil folgen möchten
ganz wichtig hier zur erinnerung aktuell
liegen in der datenbank nur dinge die
mit der un terrorliste zu tun haben oder
die durch den krisen protokoll ausgelöst
wurden aber genau das soll sich ändern
und auch wenn man vordergründig um viel
offenheit bemüht ist ganz vieles bleibt
doch sehr sehr interessant weil 2020 ist
das city offiziell eine andy auch
personal geld und technik stamme aber
weitestgehend noch von den großen
gründer blatt vor
ja wir jetzt wissen wenn ihr die meisten
entscheidungen aktuell noch von der
plattform selbst getroffen selbst der
chef der gitti sagt er hat nicht so ganz
den überblick über die datenbank und
findet in herrsching prozess aktuell
auch noch sehr intransparent das heißt
da ist noch sehr vieles im umbruch aber
gerade werden da die weichen gestellt
für ein tool zur regulierung von
terroristischen inhalte im internet und
deswegen muss man auch so genau
hingucken helfen soll in den prozess und
innerhalb der ngo ein unabhängiges
beratergremium darin sitzen 21
mitglieder aus unterschiedlichen
regierung wie zum beispiel aus
frankreich aber auch menschen aus der eu
und aber auch menschen aus wissenschaft
und gesellschaft und die sollen zusammen
kontrollieren was da passiert und sie
haben aber kein bieter das ist auch der
grund weshalb ganz viele grundrechts
organisationen gesagt haben wir wollen
in diesem gremium nicht mitmachen weil
wir eigentlich nur dazu dienen den
anschein zu erwecken hier würden grund
und menschenrechte eingehalten
aber das was wir sagen was wir an
vorschlägen machen wird mehr oder
weniger ignoriert
im sommer 2020 haben 15 große andy aus
der geschieht ihre absage erteilt sie
wollen nicht teil des beratergremiums
sein denn sie sehen die meinungsfreiheit
durch das forum gefährdet ganz anders
sehen das eu und bundesregierung
das innenministerium hat mir geschrieben
es sieht nur eine hypothetische gefahr
dass auch legale inhalte betroffen sein
könnten und betont die zusammenarbeit
der unternehmen untereinander im gips
city ist ein wichtiger baustein im kampf
gegen terroristische und extremistische
internetinhalte und wird daher durch die
bundesregierung positiv bewertet was
eigentlich für alle fest steht extreme
gewalt aufrufe zu terror hinrichtung und
so weiter sollten nicht einfach so im
internet zur verfügung stehen aber die
große sorge von wissenschaftlern vom
netz aktivisten von enders und so weiter
ist das wenn sich so eine struktur zur
regulierung von inhalten zwischen
unternehmen und gegebenenfalls auch noch
mit behörden einmal etabliert hat dann
kann die kopiert und weiterentwickelt
werden
die frage ist hat man damit ein modell
was von licht demokratischen staaten
kopiert werden kann was sie dann auch
genutzt denn kann sollten sich irgendwo
regierung ändern und kann es auch für
weitere inhalte dann einfach kopiert
werden
die gif stephen root quasi darauf dass
das ganze diese regulierungs geschichte
schon bei kinderpornografischen inhalten
einigermaßen gut funktioniert jetzt ist
natürlich die frage wenn man das jetzt
bei terror auch etabliert wie geht es
dann weiter gilt das dann auch
irgendwann für fake news
falschinformationen einfluss von außen
und so weiter da es hat dann einfach die
befürchtung schafft man damit ein modell
für internet regulierung dass man danach
das nicht mehr einfangen kann
also ich bin sehr skeptisch dass wenn
man sowas einmal eingeführt hat dass
sich demokratisch kontrollieren lässt
und auch wirklich sich auf die inhalte
beschränkt die vom kontext unabhängig
illegal sind
denn das sind die allerwenigsten inhalte
ich würde nicht sagen dass wir sowas
nicht brauchen ich würde sagen so was
wie irgend eine datenbank an
problematischen
die auch tatsächlich dann gelöscht
werden und muss existieren im
allerbesten fall entwickelt sich das
gäste tief von einem industriekonsortium
hin zu einer transparenten und
kontrollierbaren andy auch veränderungen
in der struktur braucht es dafür auf
jeden fall weg rasmussen der chef betont
ja auch immer wieder dass er auf kritik
eingehen will
er schreibt auch terroristen und
gewalttätige extremisten an der nutzung
digitaler plattform zu hindern können
nur gelingen wenn gleichzeitig
grundlegende menschenrechte ausgebaut
werden mehr beteiligung von externen
akteuren die auch tatsächlich da halt
nicht beteiligt sind die aber 100%
einsicht haben accountability im sinne
von die daten die sachen die gemacht
werden müssen auf jeden fall dauerhaft
gespeichert werden sie fordern
verbesserungen julia räder geht einen
schritt weiter
würde er sagen öffentliche stellen
sollten sich daran nicht beteiligen weil
sie dadurch ihre verantwortung umgehen
eben sich an rechtsstaatliche standards
zu halten und in einem rechtsstaat ist
es halt so dass ein gericht darüber
entscheidet was legal und was illegal
ist und nicht einfach irgendeine behörde
ohne dass es darüber irgendwie
demokratische kontrolle gibt eine
einfache lösung für dieses problem gibt
es nicht und ohne irgendeine form der
zusammenarbeit zwischen den plattform
wird es vermutlich auch nicht gehen das
heißt man braucht an der stelle einfach
mehr transparenz eine kontrollinstanz
und mehr accountability und dafür
braucht das thema zunächst erst mal viel
mehr aufmerksamkeit
aktuell muss man noch nicht davon
ausgehen dass sie ist eine riesige lösch
maschine ist aber die struktur die da
angelegt wird
die ist anfällig für fehler und durch
ihre intransparenz auch anfällig für
missbrauch und was ich jetzt daraus
entwickelt darauf muss man ganz genau
gucken denn um das einfach nicht zu
beobachten
dafür hat die gipse die schon zu viel
macht
[Musik]
danke dass sie bei so einem wichtigen
thema und aber doch auch ein bisschen
trocknen und komplizierten thema bis zum
ende dran geblieben seid wenn ihr euch
für meinungsfreiheit allgemein
interessiert und zwar von einem ganz
anderen blickwinkel noch mal könnt ihr
euch hier das video von meiner kollegin
mal angucken da geht es um kämpferischer
und hier unten findet ihr die summen
playlist wir freuen uns wie immer wenn
ihr vorbeischaut und wenn ihr wollt sagt
uns doch mal in den kommentaren was für
themen euch sonst noch interessieren
würden